your credibility will go downhill among
the YouTube Community people are mostly
interested in what you have to say
because you work at Amazon when you're
disconnected from a real job will people
take you seriously if you're just a
YouTuber well that's pretty harsh I
sometimes ask myself how the next
generation will be seems like
Millennials and gen Z just don't
understand what hard work means it's all
about becoming famous and getting likes
nowadays so around two months ago I
posted this video announcing that I left
my job at AWS to become a full-time
YouTuber the video went kind of viral
and somehow sparked a bit of a debate in
the comments on one hand I had people
who were incredibly supportive and
shared their stories and experiences
with me but I also received some
comments that were just not very nice I
know on the internet people are afraid
to say whatever they want but I do think
there's a bit of misguided information
out there or what it's actually like
pursuing a career that is not a
traditional nine-to-five job one of the
biggest questions I've gotten is do you
regret quitting your job at edibus you
know with company layoffs and everything
go going on with the world do you think
you made a mistake leaving a stable
high-paying Tech Career the short answer
is no I believe this has been one of the
best career decisions I've ever made
even though some people think otherwise
in this video I want to walk you through
my thought process of why I decided to
abandon everything I had at AWS you know
the steady income free business travel
and Company perks to pursue something
that doesn't provide any of that by the
way I want to make it clear that I had a
great experience working at AWS and
learned a lot during my two years as a
Solutions architect people were
speculating whether I left because I
hated my job but that just wasn't the
case for me alright so in the I quit my
job at AWS video I listed three reasons
why I decided to leave my job to become
a full-time YouTuber the first reason is
because I love making videos and helping
out the cloud Community second reason is
because I believe there's potential for
Tech with Lucy to grow even further and
impact more people and finally money and
the long-term earning potential of
YouTube for me this pretty much
translates into happiness fulfill
government and financial flexibility
which are three factors I really value
when choosing a career it took me around
two years to learn the whole process of
how to make high quality engaging videos
and so when I did make the jump to doing
YouTube full-time I knew that I could
still continue adding value to the tech
with Lucy Community even if I didn't
have the badge of honor or credibility
of being a Solutions architect at AWS it
really wasn't a decision I made
overnight so as scary as it was I knew I
was going to be okay and I'm definitely
not alone on this journey there's been
many Tech YouTubers over the years who
have quit their jobs to make videos
full-time which brings me on to a reason
I didn't mention in my previous video
[Music]
and yes I'm going to be brutally honest
with all of you starting with this clip
from garyvee that perfectly explains
what I want to say I'm sure at this
point plenty of people have heard about
the great resignation the thing that I'm
way more worried about as all of you go
on your journey to build the things that
you want to build is the great never
applying in the first place the amount
of options 17 19 22 year olds have going
into the world and they're aware of it
of how easy it is to make sixty thousand
dollars a year flipping on eBay making
content on Tick Tock there are so many
more options than what we grew up with
if you're over 35 here that it's
profound you have to understand what's
coming up the ranks these are 15 17 19
year olds that aren't lazy that are not
entitled that are not soft they have
options this is not about they don't
want to work this is about I'm 16 and I
make 250 000 a year on YouTube ads this
is not they're soft this is they're
smart what I've come to realize is that
hard work is not necessarily a direct
reflection of a better career so to
address this YouTube comment it's not
about being famous and getting lots of
likes it's about leveraging YouTube as a
platform to help others and share
valuable content at scale the barrier of
Entry to starting your own side business
or side hustle is much lower these days
you don't need to buy inventory or rent
an expensive warehouse and to make
YouTube videos all you really need is a
phone and a laptop so even though a
high-paying job is a very good option
and can bring along great future
prospects it's important to be aware
that there are also other ways to make
money and it's all about finding what
works best for you before I move on to
the next reason which is a bit more of a
personal one I'd like to take a moment
to introduce today's video response on
nordvpn a VPN stands for virtual private
Network and it's a service that protects
your internet connection and privacy
online nordvpn is an easy to use VPN
service that enables you to access
content from all over the world whilst
keeping your data and applications safe
whether you want to hide your IP address
or access content only offered in
certain countries series lordvpn allows
you to open up a map click on the
location and get connected in seconds
they now offer threat protection which
is a major upgrade that blocks intrusive
ads and web trackers so if you download
a file it will inspect for malware it
also automatically scans URLs and blocks
malicious ones if you're looking for a
VPN service you can head to nordvpn.com
forward slash lucitech to get a two-year
plan plus four additional months with a
huge discount okay so the next reason is
a bit more of a personal one and
depending on your personality type this
might resonate with you
as an infp if you're into 16 personality
types I'm naturally someone who really
enjoys alone time and loves to
understand the big picture before I work
on something with YouTube I have this
broad vision of I want to help people
build their technical skills and land a
job in the cloud industry but it's
pretty much a plain canvas and I'm given
the creative freedom to decide how I
want to achieve that Vision you might
think being a YouTuber is only for
extroverts and people who love being a
fan of the camera but it can actually be
quite a lonely process when you think
about it you're spending hours every day
come up with new video ideas writing a
script and talking in front of a camera
by yourself so even though being a
YouTuber or full-time content creator
was never something I had as a childhood
dream ever it surprisingly aligns quite
well with my personality and what I
enjoy
foreign
that YouTube won't be around forever if
tech company layoffs and hiring freezes
have taught us anything it's that no
good opportunity will be around forever
it's the skills you develop from your
experiences that stay with you let's say
you have a friend working as a senior
software developer in a tech company who
suddenly loses their job chances are
they'll be able to find a new job in a
similar position and won't have to start
over as a junior developer the same
concept applies with being a full-time
YouTuber so if YouTube goes down as a
platform all the skills you develop from
making videos and running a business can
be directly transferable to other social
media platforms and even other
Industries anyways that's enough from me
this is not the type of video I normally
make so let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed it and I'll see you
soon bye for now